let's see I mean let's just just to do
it because we haven't heard from him for
a while let's get Jimmy from Philly on
the phone and see what is on his mind
Jimmy from Philly what's going on Jimmy
from Philly hey della good how are you
David how are you
you must be drunk it's 11:00 right no
I'm not drunk
Thanks do you want to give me a thousand
dollars a month a thousand
yeah uh-huh so you're voting yes isn't
that what he said
thousand hours a month right that was I
love them so I'm holding young no I'm
not how many beers no no or we can date
he's the only one who makes any sense
because he's talking about giving me
cash okay so you like free stuff is what
you're saying I like cash and has Trump
giving you any yeah I got a raise here
Trump gave you the raise that's
interesting yeah no Jimmy how many beers
have you had earlier I had a few but
yeah yeah how many I mean like I had a
few vodka drinks too so oh yeah how many
how many are there 12% ours do you think
you had I have any other oh okay Jimmy
very good anything else on the agenda uh
you know none of those clowns are gonna
be Trump
very good okay just not gonna happen
it's not gonna happen David you and you
know it everybody knows it binds to
frontrunner it doesn't matter what Biden
says er does he's gonna be the nominee
and Biden was a joke tonight but you
know you and I agree Biden did not do
well tonight and I actually I wouldn't
be surprised if Biden is not leading the
polls two weeks from today because his
performance was truly not good but
Bernie isn't the one that they want
right
we'll see okay Jamie very good good to
hear from you I'm sure you've got our
lady and all of that stuff
so we will we'll let you go all right
give me very good Jimmy for filly